what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder happy Halloween to
everybody there's been some rumors going
around that Disney might cancel the
Thunderbolts movie and blade a lot of
people have been asking me about this so
I wanted to do a quick video about it
talking about the report but talking
about the actual possibility of this
being true now obviously there have been
some problems with some projects over at
Marvel Studios due to the actor strike
and the writer strike and unfortunately
this can complicate things for the
future because because it sets the
shooting schedules back and actors book
multiple things at a time so some actors
for the Thunderbolts might have
something booked for when the filming
finally begins again so there could be
some scheduling problems that really do
affect some films David Harbor is one of
those people who could possibly have
some of those complications due to the
filming of the Thunderbolts being pushed
back while at the same time he has to
film stranger things season 5 this could
put the Thunderbolts in general blade
has also had itsv fair share of problems
and the concern right now even before
the report was that Mersa Ali might not
be satisfied and might back out from the
film and as Kevin fogy stated before
they decided to do blade because of
mersa Ali and you got to admit he really
really does look like blade however
although this all may sound pretty bad
fortunately for us it's most likely not
true this report is coming from an
account Empire City box office and they
stated yesterday hearing that Disney and
Marvel Studios are not moving forward
with the Thunderbolts once the strike is
over this week also hear that blade is
in serious Jeopardy as well here's the
good news Empire City box office is not
known for Scoops they track box office
numbers pretty well but typically don't
have inside information and Insider
Daniel rpk who has a pretty good track
record responded to this tweet stating
not true which we very much hope is the
case and presume it is plus not to
mention the Thunderbolts is going to be
an incredibly important movie moving
forward in the MCU and it combines a lot
of characters from other franchises in
the MCU as well even if one of them
somehow couldn't make it due to
scheduling problems they would probably
just exclude that character but it
involves a major cast they're not just
going to cancel a movie that is crucial
for the story of the MCU that is
important and has a major cast it not
only connects to the past but also to
the Future and it's supposedly going to
be a pretty big film for the X-Men from
what we've heard tyut who now is going
to be referred to as basically a
Celestial Island has adamantium on it
which we all know is the metal that is
inside of Wolverine so there's some
pretty big future implications that are
supposed to happen with the Thunderbolts
also with blade as well with the
supernatural side of the MCU these are
both really big movies for Marvel I
don't think that they would just flat
out cancel these movies I think if
anything they would make adjustments and
do rewrites much like they have many
times already for blade so the good news
is Daniel rpk says this is not true we
most likely are going to be getting the
Thunderbolts and blade moving forward I
would fully expect us to get them and I
wouldn't really worry about this new
report but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
and this is the last day for the
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X a PlayStation 5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items all you
got to do is subscribe and leave a
comment down below to enter we pick a
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item last day
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof